this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armories museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode we're back for a second
part of jonathan's look at the madness
of borderlands 3. unsurprisingly a
shoulder fired flat gun uh is a risk to
the user i don't want to tell you
shoot explosive shells out of a
shoulder-fired gun it's probably going
to be a bad day for you as well as the
enemy
if you want to see more of jonathan's
take on borderlands 3 make sure to
subscribe and check out our previous
episode on the game's firearms if there
any other games guns or mechanics that
you guys want to see nothing breakdown
let us know in the comment section below
right let's get back to the guns of
borderlands 3.
very much a sci-fi pistol i'm not sure
about the little bubbly grip textures
that's where texture tends not to be
grippy enough for it for a pistol you
want something more like skateboard tape
than you do little bumps but it has you
know it's a it's a nod toward
functionality at least trigger looks
like it wouldn't really function as a
trigger other than for an electrical
directed energy weapon which i'm
guessing this is some sort of given the
dials and general configuration of it
it's a little bit reminiscent of the
maxim 9 which is an integral
suppressor pistol so you have you have
actual modules you can add to create a
more suppressed but more
less wieldy
gun or shorter gun that's handier but a
bit louder it has a similar sort of
silhouette to this but it doesn't have
that knuckle bow double trigger guard so
this has a trigger guard on its trigger
guard so you can trigger guard while you
trigger guard i don't know it's it's
redundant design
right so this is an energy weapon as
predicted with two different types of
ammunition luckily it tells you what
they are so incendiary clearly that's
going to set characters on fire and also
shock rounds which i presume will have a
stun effect so far so good but
so that that big chunky front end that
honor something like the maxim 9 would
be a design feature to accommodate
either either a mechanical change or in
case of the maxim nine it'll suppress a
space in this case it's part of this
mythical energy weapon but it's also a
front grip so i guess we have a reason
for that second trigger guard in that
it's a stop for your hand for a
two-handed pistol the thing is a
two-handed pistol doesn't make a huge
amount of sense you want the whole point
of a pistol is that it's portable
compact you can carry it around all day
you have to put two hands in it now of
course modern pistol technique is two
hands all the way if possible for
stability and accuracy but something
that looks to require that you hold it
two hands because it's that chunky and
heavy you may as well have something
with a stop on it and be able to deliver
more accurate fire and this has no
capability of fitting a stock to it i'm
overthinking it
all right well the
gears of war-esque permanently attached
sword bayonet that has zero penetration
because it barely sticks forward of the
muzzle so it's more of a cutting weapon
and then the rear part of the blade is
compromised because it has bikes that
get in the way of that the edge glows so
is it some sort of plasma nanotech blade
i don't know it has a serrated top of
the blade as as real blades often do but
you can't use the top of the back of the
blade i should say because it's attached
to the gun and can't be taken off so
that doesn't make any sense and that's
just the tip of the iceberg because this
thing is some sort of tesla punk
nightmare it's probably the best
description i can come up with and the
right hand side is even more insane than
the left the sights are completely
bonkers as well i'm seeing a bicycle
chain on this thing now there are real
world guns that are driven or have
chains in them the huge chain gun being
perhaps the most notable of those
electrical motor driving the breach of a
gun with a length of chain um wheel lock
firearms going way way back have a short
length of chain connecting the main
spring to the wheel itself and there are
a couple of others so weirdly enough
although it's a bonkers feature to see
on this equally bonkers gun
that at least has some parallel in
reality let's just have a look at how it
works shall we
check out that body count
well i mean it is some a conventional
firearm in that it has bullets or fires
some kind of conventional ammunition i
think although it's not entirely clear
to me what's energy and what's not but
it sounds like a gun it's got barrels
it's got a feed shoot reminiscent of
something on an aircraft there's a lot
going on here it's insane using
incendiary rounds of some kind and then
there's some chance of it catching on
fire and you then have to pour liquid on
it to put it out which seems like a
fairly fatal design floor sure guns get
really hot when you shoot them a lot but
um
spontaneously catching fire
is not usual so it seems that if this
thing gets too flamey you actually do a
barrel swap sort of the whole front of
the gun comes off and you replace it of
course that's a real thing that we get
with firearms to prevent excessive wear
to the barrel you replace the barrel on
a sustained fire gun and then if you
have two barrels by the time you fire
another 200 rounds or whatever your
original barrel is now cool enough to
use again rinse and repeat uh you
generally don't shoot the barrel to
destruction pull the barrel off and slap
a new one on i'm not even sure where
you'd carry that
this the the so-called disciplined
warlord is probably the most
conventional gun i've seen yet it's got
the obligatory science fiction thumb
hole stock which is not a great idea on
a machine gun weird
hints there of ar-15
m16a2 pistol grip a little bit and the
trigger and the trigger guard remind me
a little bit of that but
a fairly 20th century looking muzzle
break on there present day angle 4 grip
but it seems to be built into the gun
rather than being an accessory and then
a 19th century frankly
cartridge and belt feed system
yeah okay we're still using the version
of that now i would hope for better or
different
in the future
very quirky system here so what looks to
be a fire selector is not a fire
selector it is changing the zoom on the
scope and the scope is
sliding its objective and ocular lenses
apart and increasing magnification don't
know why that would be a thing and i
don't know why you'd operate it using a
switch on the gun especially one that is
by
the tradition of the better part of the
century a fire selector or at least a
safety so that's a slightly perplexing
design choice
gatlin
gatling gun i don't know what they mean
by that it's a gatling gun that gatlings
i suppose what they're saying there you
can feel my iq lowering watch me crank
it watch me roll let's watch him crank
it shall we
well i don't think i'm any clearer on
what a gatling gatling gun is clearly it
has it has a hand crank that we would
expect and it appears to have
multiple very s very
slim barrels inside
a shroud i mean i'm surprised it doesn't
have expo an exposed barrel cluster
because that's the
signature feature of a gatling gun it
has the crank which is the second signal
signature feature of
non-electric gatling guns but it has
this weird drum
car wheel magazine thing and it's not
clear where the rounds go
in that and as you crank it spins and
somehow it's chambering and firing and
all that i don't follow it seems to be
very much an impression of how a gun
works the only way it can work is if we
have
five magazines
mounted onto a hub essentially and each
one in sequence
aligns with the feed lips that are on
the outer rim of the
drum
thing i mean there's no way that could
work but that has to be the way it's
supposed to work so each spoke feeds
around one after the other so one two
three four five one three four five
until all of the spokes are empty is the
best i can do on that one
all right i think i recognize a quite
two style space shotgun when i see one
and it based on its name
and the sort of damage modifiers and the
general appearance of it i'm pretty
confident this is going to be a sort of
shotgun that fires big hot chunks of
metal
uh nope it's not that i should have
taken it more literally it fires literal
flaxshells we've had exploding artillery
shells for a very long time so you shoot
them like a conventional munition or
cannonball effectively
but they are a shell a hollow metal
sphere originally filled with some
explosive content and they burst and the
idea is as an anti-aircraft weapon
because we didn't have aircraft until
the beginning of the 20th century that
so the same basic technology used
essentially as a giant shotgun on the
battlefield against infantry now becomes
in modern form
a way to make sure that aircraft fly
into shards of metal which doesn't do a
lot for the aircraft's ability to stay
in the air that's the idea you've seen
any war movie with aircraft bursts of
flat going off that's that's this but in
a shoulder fired package now i was going
to say the obvious disadvantage of that
with it with a flak anti-aircraft gun
the bursting is happening
hundreds of meters away from you so
you've got no chance of fragging
yourself in this case
unsurprisingly a shoulder fired flat gun
uh is a risk to the user and we saw some
significant splash damage there i don't
know what to tell you
shoot explosive shells out of a shoulder
fired gun
it's probably gonna be a bad day for you
as well as the enemy
wedding invitation of all of the names
for guns that i've seen wedding
invitation is probably the weirdest
uh i will say that the aesthetic of this
thing is somewhat different to what i've
seen so far hard to describe another
take on the perennial thumbhole stock
which is
seemingly purely for aesthetics
interesting
very very long scope john i'm not
really sure why you need such a long
scope on
an advanced weapon
didn't see the revolver sniper rifle
nature of this coming but there it is
weirdly we've got a bit of real world
here
right in the back there we have what
i've previously referred to as the rolo
cocking handle of a
swiss k31 straight pull
rifle and we have the ring pull
cocking piece
of a rifle of that family but for some
reason the cocking piece is how you
shoot this thing or i guess it's no i
guess it's more the
the cocking handle is ornamental and the
cocking piece is the cocking handle and
then we're somehow using that to fire it
really quickly and then it's also a
revolver with a swing out cylinder and
my brain hurts there is a nod toward
functionality in that we have to rock
the scope out of the way to swing the
cylinder out for reloading so i guess
that's that's good except that that
would not lend itself to
accuracy
and retaining zero with your scope if
you're constantly rocking it in and out
of alignment you can do that with a
magnifier because it's not changing the
point of aim of the actual optic in
front of it you can't do it with an
optical sight but then with future
technology why would you have a straight
pull revolver rifle
another possible reality
check
is that swollen foregrip
which is
reminiscent of the british em2 bullpup
rifle probably inspired by it but it
isn't by any means a straight copy of it
so it could be coincidence but i'm going
to cling to what's left of my sanity and
say that that might be that's a
combination of a revolver rifle
revolving rifle a swiss k-31 and a
british em-2 with a bit of modern blocky
suppressor
front-end
aesthetic thrown in for good measure and
a conventional scope and scope mount but
it's not conventional because it swings
out of the way
okay squinting very hard i can sort of
see uzi here that pistol grip and
especially the grips and the magazine in
the pistol grip even though there's a
second magazine of completely different
shape in front of it but that i think is
for the underbarrel weapon makes this
sort of like a highly modified uzi you
could almost see a movie making this by
putting an uzi in a housing of some sort
definite easy inspiration i can
confidently say let's find out what the
hell this thing does
[Music]
oh wow this is this is breaking me we've
got two fire modes clearly labeled
pistol and double barrel but we have
three magazines
one at the back with visible rounds
there's the uzi style one in the pistol
grip and then there's the rifle styled
one up front and then the fire modes are
feeding from like one fireman the pistol
fire mode firing mode fires from one of
those magazines i think the middle one
and then the double barrel mode fires
from
all three of them so two but
even though there are three barrels on
the top section and then a fourth barrel
on the bottom but the fire mode is
called double barrel and this is like
something from a fever dream and i think
i'm just gonna give up
[Music]
join us again next time and in the
meantime if you'd like to donate to us
there are links in the description
goodbye
[Music]
you